Good evening everyone. My name is Rick
Tiaan. I'm 24 years old from Bugar and
currently I'm working as an
>> Speak in the mic. Speak loudly but
slowly. We can't hear you.
>> Okay. Good evening everyone. Yes,
>> my name is Rick Yawan. I'm from Bugar
and currently working as business
analyst and I am agnostic.
Okay. Uh sir
uh
you said many times before that Quran is
perfectly perfect or perceived unlike
other religious scripture. But even with
that preservation Muslims still differ
in interpreting it just as Jews,
Christians, Hindus and others do with
their own text. So uh in the end who
decides which understanding is right and
how can we be sure if it's God that
we're seeking not just a confirmation of
what we already believe and if love
humility and sincere surrender are the
essence of all true religion. Is it
possible that someone outside of Islam
but deeply sincere could be a closer to
God than someone who simply follows a
label or wins a debate?
>> The brother as a question that I believe
that Quran is the word of God. It is
perfect. There are no mistakes but yet
there are different interpretation.
Correct. That's the question first part.
Second part that can a person who's not
a Muslim
can he be closer to God is your second
question. Correct sir?
>> Yes.
>> Regarding the first part the Quran is
verbbitim the word of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala. While translating they can be a
choice of word. Translating the Quran
there can be a choice of word but the
Arabic is purely the word of God.
There's only one word. There are no two
words. But translations can differ.
There can be understanding problem or
differences but the Arabic is the same.
When there is a difference if one verse
can have two different meaning you have
to go to the hadith of the prophet. The
hadith is the commentary of the Quran.
So when we read the say hadith the say
hadith gives us more information. If one
verse can mean two things then we go to
the hadith and check up. In the hadith
we get tapir the tapir of the Quran the
commentary of the Quran is a hadith it
has more details. So if you know the
hadith well you'll if a verse can have
two meanings then the hadith will tell
you which meaning is correct or many a
time even both are correct. Coming to
your second question can a person who's
not a Muslim be closer to God? What is
the definition of the word Muslim?
Muslim means one who submits his will to
Almighty God. Non-Muslim is a person who
does not submit his will to Almighty
God. So your question is can a person
who does not submit his will to God be
better than a person who submits his
will to God?
Have you understood?
>> Your question to me is
>> yes sir.
>> Can a non-Muslim non-Muslim means a
person who does not submit his will to
God? Can he be closer to God than a
Muslim? So in English, if I translate
your question, can a person who does not
submit his will to God be closer to God
than a person who submits his will to
God? Can you answer your question?
>> Do you understand what I'm saying?
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, have you understood the fallacy, the
problem in your question?
>> Yes.
>> That means no. The answer is no. That
means a person who is a non-Muslim, a
person who doesn't submit his will to
God cannot be closer than a person who
submits his will to God. A non-Muslim
cannot be closer to God than a Muslim.
You got the answer.
>> Okay, I got it.
>> Brother, do you believe in God?
>> I do believe in oneness of God.
>> Mashallah. Do you believe that Prophet
Muhammad is a messenger of God? I do
believe uh Muhammad is just one of God's
stuff uh just like us to help God run uh
the system.
>> He is a human being for sure. But I'm
asking you, do you believe is the
messenger of God?
>> Yes, he's one of the messenger of God.
>> Yes, one of there are many messengers,
hundreds and thousands. Mashallah. So
brother in Islam there are two things
required. One is believe that God is one
and do you believe Jesus is God?
>> No.
>> Mashallah. Do you believe Jesus is a
messenger of God?
>> Yes.
>> Very good.
So in Islam there are minimum two
criterias required for a person to enter
Islam. Number one believe there is one
God. Number two believe that Prophet
Muhammad is a messenger of God. After
that slowly and slowly a person starts
following. But the minimum two things
you already believe. So do you want to
would you like to accept Islam?
M maybe I do want to keep it private
between me and God. So
>> I want to keep it private.
>> Okay. As long as you follow God, you
believe in God, that's perfect. You
don't have to proclaim in front of the
public. I ask Allah to give you haya.
And may Allah subhanana wa ta'ala guide
you. And may you come closer to God,
brother.